when the events of this film transpired
Jason you were 11 years old living in
Canada so this is kind of like making a
film about Abraham Lincoln for you and
so so what got your attention about this
how did this come to you I should say at
that point I I was living in Los Angeles
and had a green card okay but was the
child of Canadians this story my journey
really started three years ago when I
heard a radio lab piece on Matt by his
book on Gary Hart and I frankly I just
couldn't believe that there was a moment
in our recent history that the presumed
next president of the United States
wound up in an alleyway in the middle of
the night with a group of journalists
and nobody knew what to do because no
one had ever been in their shoes before
and the more I thought about the story
and the the more I talked to friends
about it the more just it seemed as
though it had all this connective tissue
with everything we're talking about
today whether it's gender politics or
the line between a public life and a
private life or the relationship between
candidates and and journalists it seemed
to touch on all of these ideas that we
are all trying to figure out and and
look I make movies because I have
questions I'm like anyone else here I'm
trying to wonder how the hell did we get
here and and I thought this seemed like
an interesting thread to pull on and so
you called Matt I reached out to Matt
and Matt and Jay were already working
together on this and this look this is
an unusual screenplay in that it was
co-written by Matt by the New York Times
Magazine journalists covered five
different presidents presidential
elections Jake Carson who political
operative was the press secretary for
Hillary Clinton in oh wait and Howard
Dean Tom Dowd works with senators
Bradley Schumer Tom Daschle yeah and of
course me the son of the director of
Ghostbusters so I think but of course we
all had valuable experience that made
sense for this film but look this is we
decided early on that well this is a
movie that centers around one person it
has 20 main characters we want
to be as much from the point of view of
the people on the campaign the point of
view of his family the point of view of
the various journalists and it was
written on the shoulders of their
experience to start with what is
essentially a tale of a fulcrum moment
in American politics and to get it to
the screen there are great great
political stories out there but not all
of them get told in this fashion no I
think very few get told in this in this
fashion I mean I think what was it's
it's obviously you know the the he was
based on the book but the book is very
sprawling and as you know we talked
about it it's you know I covers a lot of
territory before and after the scandal I
think to adapt this you needed we needed
sort of a unity of creative vision and I
think you know the first time we all sat
down Jason and Jay and I we we all
wanted to tell the same story which is
not just the true story but a story that
was that showed the complexity of all
the people involved no heroes and
villains
she always says but but to have it be to
give everybody their perspective to make
a movie that wasn't going to hit people
over the head and tell them what to
think that was that was you know a big
challenge and we all wanted it to feel
super real and like you'd been dropped
into a world and hopefully you feel that
way where you know sometimes you have to
catch ups frankly sometimes it might be
a little confusing but but we're you
know you have the sense that you're
really dropped into something and that
that feels very authentic I think that
the fact that we were all in the same
creative page made adapting this not
only very doable but you know super fun
but between the two of us you know Matt
and I've done eight presidential
campaigns and we're often turned off by
you know a lot of what we the portrayals
of that world that we'd seen before
because you end up with one-dimensional
archetypal characters good guys and bad
guys black hats and white hats heroes
and villains and in all of our time in
in Washington which is a lot you know we
never met any through-and-through heroes
we never met any
maybe Metta through a few through a few
through and through villains but no it
was important it was important for us in
this not to as matt said not to have it
be a message movie but to have it feel
like the world that we spent so much
time in and that world is a world
populated by human beings whether
they're journalists or candidates or
voters or spouses or staffers they're
all human beings and I think humans make
the three-dimensional humans make the
best characters they're all human beings
who are in difficult spots usually under
a lot of pressure facing something that
they don't know how to do and they're
trying to do their best that it in this
case Matt had stumbled upon this period
where people were facing something for
the very first time this had never
happened before to any of them so we
watched these human being struggle in
that and it was great to have Jason
pushing us to go even further and deeper
into reality you know it was just it was
a really inspiring I really a joyous
experience from the very very first time
we sat down and start breaking story
Helen as one of the producers with Jason
and a couple of other folks was this a
hard sell was it oh god another politics
movie was it that was 30 years ago or
was it a natural well we were very lucky
we did Jason and I did tell this movie
telly with Aaron Gilbert and that sort
of partnership of the three of us for
that movie and I mean there were more
producers I went to but that for the
became a sort of way we had such an easy
way to talk about it creatively and talk
about the ideas and so we were given a
lot of support because it was you know I
think this amazing script that they
wrote and obviously Hughes involvement
and yeah it was it's funny I think on
the surface it looks sort of sort of the
elevator pitch seems a bit difficult but
we felt like it was we were very
supported throughout and yeah so Eric
obviously this is a film about a
specific period not just an era but a
few months in a specific year and you
evoked it with some of the the hardware
of the moment like a phone booth which
you can tell your children is a small
very tiny room with a phone in it that
you pick up and make calls for
and yet it wasn't over-the-top it wasn't
so detailed how did you find that place
where you were suggestive of the look of
the period without making it sort of
anal compulsive like everything has to
be exactly correct down to the menus I
think we came from a place of simplicity
Jason I referenced a lot of movies that
were shot in the 70s funny and huffing
that we're doing moving the eighties
because there was simplicity to the
filmmaking a lot of long shots kind of a
lo-fi a low-tech approach so we sourced
a lot of equipment lights lenses and we
kind of let that dictate how we were
going to move forward and where we're
gonna put our pointer camera how long
we're gonna let shots run how we're
gonna block scenes and it created a new
way of working for us that we hadn't
done which was really exciting because
we were bouncing between all these
points of view in the story and plot
lines and places we shot on film again
and we shot on film
film on film since first film on film
since up in the air and this there's
that magical thing that happened that I
had kind of forgotten because we had
made so many movies digitally since up
in the air that when you actually roll
the whole set knows when you when you
turn on the digital camera if I'm people
don't know you'd see hitting button and
nothing really has changed but when you
actually roll film and it's like you lit
a fuse and you can hear it there's that
electricity to it and I I didn't realize
how much I missed that and the look of
it to has it's like the difference
between vinyl and digital music I think
yeah well look we made an early decision
and this started in the writing and it
continued through the acting and then
the cinematography which was look the
philosophy of the film is what is
important right this is the question
that we're all asking today it's the
question the film is asking what is
relevant versus what is entertaining
these days you know you wake up in the
morning you open your phone you look at
the news app and there's a there's a
story about the midterms and right next
to it is a story about the breakup of
ariana grande and Pete Davidson and and
they're both put out by the Washington
Post and they're both given equal weight
and it's very hard to tell which one of
these is the real story which one is
politics and which one is entertainment
and so if we're gonna be asking this
question philosophically of the audience
what we all began to discuss was okay
how can we ask this question
cinematically and it starts with that
opening shot where we're presenting ten
different conversations that are all
overlapped from actors you don't know at
first of which who is important who is
unimportant we're introducing you know
the history of the character which is
playing on a TV we're introducing the
technology of there the fact that the
satellite truck had just changed and
created a 24-hour news cycle and we're
and our sound mixer it was miking every
actor on set at all times and live
mixing all their dialogue which was
which was partly improvised so the idea
yes indeed
he played his mixer like a piano and a
lot of Lee heard today was the
production mix of the dialogue so I
think we were all playing with this idea
of how do we ask this question at all
times through all departments of you
know what is important all the way down
to the last shot of the film where
there's a television on one side of the
screen and there is a marriage on the
other and on the television is this
speech the the most important speech
Gary Hart probably ever made was this
final speech as a politician and on the
other side is a marriage holding on for
dear life and we're asking you all the
way to the last moments what do you
actually want to look at you when you
portray a real person you want to convey
rather than imitate I would think so how
did you build Gary Hart's character well
this is the second time I played a real
character Wolverine was the first and I
tried to find him he's impossible
so he didn't review your performance
like oh no I've had I mean this means
several incidents in my houses I presume
a him you know or raccoons yeah all
recognize now I was nervous about it
obviously hoping presuming that he would
see the movie and so in preparation
obviously have an amazing resource
because these guys have been
I knew him very well and spent a lot of
time with him and writing the book and I
spent time with his campaign team and I
had incredible help from a woman called
Amy Stephens who's an incredible
dramaturg and researcher who helped me
put together like scripted from books
and interviews but also video footage
over 60 hours of video footage but it
was never our goal to actually
physically imitate Gary there was I
listened a lot to his speeches because
he had a particular way of speaking
publicly and privately it was very brief
it was to the point it was simple it was
clear and impress conferences I thought
really unusual for a politician I mean I
dragged on and on and on he would be
very clear and very quick and so I
wanted to get that so I would listen to
his voice to get clues but it's more
about getting the essence of someone
rather than doing for me then doing a
really perfect clear imitation we did
the wig we had that discussion so we do
the hair or not but I have to you got it
everyone talks about Gary Hart's here so
we had to do something with that what's
it your hair or a wig it was a week I
couldn't pull off the hair I try please
thank the panel